Socialism is responsible for 100 million deaths
More people than Fascism.
A single rocket
hitting the center of the city killed 11 people.
It also increases poverty.
So why does it appeal to so many people?
Democratic Socialism is about…
Young politicians say
Socialism will help the poor.
In a modern, moral, and wealthy society,
no person in America should be too poor to live.
That's what I think.
That seems simple.
Seems pretty simple! [applause]
Don’t they know that Socialism creates more poverty?
The oil rich country is now leading Latin America
in what is called "acute malnutrition."
Even people who understand that Socialism
is bad for the economy may not know that Socialism
almost always leads to violence.
120 people were killed during 2017.
Why does Socialism lead to violence?
Socialism gives absolute power to the state.
No one is allowed to own private property or trade
Yet everywhere under Socialism, people still do.
Mary Ann is able to find a listing for diapers,
The black market online price
is almost 10 dollars cheaper.
People have to trade on the black market to survive.
But then government gets violent.
They throw some of them in jail.
My father was a political prisoner for almost a decade
because in his 20’s he sold soaps and perfumes
and did not want to relinquish all his profits
to the government.
Capitalism sucks. Fuck Capitalism.
Today in America, capitalism is vilified
but if capitalism is so bad
why hasn’t there been a mass exodus out of America
because of Capitalism?
Sorry, you just don’t see it.
Socialism is the perfect excuse for someone
who wants to rule an authoritarian regime.
As people rebel against government controls,
the politicians, to preserve their power,
use violence to stop them.
They threw me to the floor and they started kicking me
They tortured him asking
who organized the protests?
How did you answer?
I said the people are just tired of Daniel Ortega.
Ortega has goverened Nicaragua
for 22 of the last 39 years.
In Nicaragua, people have again fallen for Daniel Ortega
and his Socialist promises.
But under his policies, Nicaragua has gone from
one of Central America's safest countries
to one of the most dangerous.
In Venezuela, where there are similar protests.
This man was a mayor in Caracas.
The Minister of Internal Affairs was calling me
several times a week asking me to use the
police department that I was in charge of
to go against protests in Chacao
The Mayor refused to have his police
punish the protesters, so he was threatened with jail.
He then escaped to America.
Why do you think Venezuela followed the same path
when we had Cuba's example for decades?
And it was terrible.
It seems to me we are not able to learn.
They will always be dreaming about the future
and never delivering.
People keep falling in love with that kind of crap.
They do!
Socialism repeateadly leads to violence.
And yet, around the world, people praise it.
I don’t think they realize how deep socialism
is involved in all that.
This man fled Nicaragua.
He understands.
America is a great country
and people really don't appreciate it much.
They should travel a little more to poor countries
to really get a feeling for what they have here
in the United States.
Look around, just look around, you know?
And really get some knowledge.